I'll start by comparing
the image's x dimension, or
its horizontal dimension here,
and on the original image.
Notice how on the site, the whole
horizontal dimension is fitting.
However, the y dimension, or
the vertical dimension,
does not entirely fit on the page.
Notice how on the original,
the image goes down far enough to
see a bit more of the tree trunk.
While on the site that part's cut off.
So for cover, the image kept
just as small as possible,
so that its smallest dimension matches
its container's smallest dimension.
However, its largest dimension
actually overflows the container.
Compare that to Contain,
in this case the y matches its container
dimensions but the x is now smaller.
Back to the statements, the first
one is going to be describing cover.
Cover ensures that the container
is completely filled,
even if that means one of the dimensions
is a little bit too large.
The second statement describes contain.
With contain, the image will
be completely visible, but
in order to do so,
that means that one of its dimensions
might be smaller than
the containers dimensions.